Hello everybody and welcome back to the
channel. Today I'll be giving you what I
dub the Jordan boyfriend experience. As
in you had to wait a full week for me to
give you a very brief and not very deep
dive. Nonetheless, let's go ahead and
talk about this notification service
because I am in a rush. The notification
service question is an interesting one
because many people doing this problem
assume that we're attempting to build
the Apple push notification service. In
reality, this isn't the case. Let's
explain APNS a bit more so that this
problem makes more sense. If a user
device had to maintain a persistent
connection to many different backends
for each app that was running on it,
we'd waste a ton of battery and cellular
data. Instead, at the operating system
level, Apple devices have one very like
connection to Apple servers, which is
responsible for delivering all
notifications. Apps from the App Store
are responsible for delivering these
notifications to the APNS service via an
API call. Keep in mind that each of
these requests to APNS are for a single
device at a time, meaning our backend
may need to send hundreds of thousands
of notification requests per second.
APNS isn't the easiest API to deal with
as a developer. As we mentioned, APNS
works at the device level as opposed to
using an application developer's user
IDs. Worse yet, what if our application
wants to send notifications to millions
of users at a time? For example, if
we're Only Fans and Jordan Has No Life69
drops a new bathwater video, we
potentially want to alert all of our
users. The engineering effort required
to solve a problem like this one isn't
trivial. If it was, we wouldn't be
making this video in the first place.
One Signal offers a simple abstraction
to its clients. The concept of a tag.
One Signal clients can attach tags to
users and specify a bunch of different
tag criteria when sending notifications.
Our API here should be fairly simple.
First off, clients of One Signal must be
able to register a user ID with its
associated device ID. Next, our clients
must be able to enroll a user ID to
belong to a given tag. Note that all tag
keys and values are stored as strings,
though internally one signal allows
doing special comparisons on tag values
if they can be parsed as numbers or
dates. Finally, our client should be
able to send notifications to a segment,
which is a grouping of tags, almost like
a query. For example, send a
notification to all users with tag
software engineer and also don't possess
tag small peen. In this example, Jordan
is the only one who receives the
notification. Apple and Google ensure
that the maximum size of a notification
for mobile devices is 4 kilobytes in
size. While one signal tags can
technically be applied to any number of
users, this video will mainly revolve
around supporting the ones with millions
or more subscribers. As of 2020, One
Signal supports scaling up to 5 billion
messages delivered per day, which could
be around 60,000 per second. Given each
message is capped at 4 kilobytes, we're
building a system to support 240
megabytes per second. Given these are
stale numbers, it seems like we should
really be aiming to be supporting
something like a gigabyte per second of
throughput. In this case, perhaps we
should be aiming for something like
250,000 notifications per second.
According to information that I see
online, APNS is a service supported by
HTTP2, which supports running many
concurrent asynchronous connections over
a single port. Prior to this,
maintaining different request response
streams with the server required opening
multiple different TCP connections from
your client device. However, in HTTP2,
you can perform both of these tactics in
tandem. I see some official estimates
that a single port can support sending
around 100 push requests simultaneously
and we could perhaps have 10 or more
connections open on our backend servers.
If each server is able to push a
thousand notifications per second,
maintaining a pool of 250 or so of them
should allow us to deliver our messages
at the throughput that we want. Since
our system is not actually delivering
the notification directly to the client
device, we don't have to maintain any
mapping from our device IDs to any
server that the device is connected to.
What this means is that any of our
servers could deliver any notifications
to any user device and APNS just
maintains one single gateway. Therefore,
we don't have to be too intelligent
about mapping notifications for certain
users to a single server. We can use a
roundrobin load balancing technique to
ensure that all 250 of our servers are
sending similar amounts of information
to APNS. One question that we should ask
ourselves when building a service like
this is whether our API calls to APNS
are item potent or not. If not, we'll
have to take a lot of care to ensure
that we don't send the same push
notification twice. Fortunately for us,
APNS supports the concept of a collapse
ID. If it receives multiple push
notifications for the same device with
the same collapse ID, only the most
recent will be kept. We can specify a
collapse ID for each API request to send
a notification, thereby ensuring that
it's okay if we send out duplicate
notifications. This is going to be the
last edition of our fanout series.
Hopefully by now you can recognize this
pattern pretty easily. We need to
deliver one message to many different
places. The work here all comes in
determining which user devices we need
to send messages to when a notification
gets created. The problem here is that
unlike many of our fanout problems up to
this point, One Signal supports a pretty
rich API when it comes to notifications.
Since notifications can go to
combinations of tags, set differences of
tags, tags based on a greater than or
less than comparison, we really can't
premp compute the set of users that will
receive an incoming notification. We'll
just have to compute this on the fly.
The design for one signal is going to
look very similar to that of our other
fanout problems. Before we jump into a
diagram, let's quickly consider the
state that we need to maintain for a
problem like this. Keep in mind that
when I use the term client ID here, I
mean one signal client ID since we'll be
building a multi-tenant architecture.
First, we need to be able to maintain a
mapping between a tag and the user IDs
it's been assigned to. Note that we're
partitioning and sorting this table in
such a way that running a query on the
value of a given tag completes fairly
quickly. Next, we need to be able to
support a mapping between an application
user ID and all of its associated device
IDs. Note that for this one, we want to
keep it partitioned just by the client
ID. When we fetch all users matching a
tag criteria, we then need to figure out
all of the associated devices. If we
ensure that all users for a given one
signal client live on the same shard,
this join operation should only touch
one node from the user mapping table. It
is possible that for certain clients
with hundreds of millions or more users,
it may take hundreds or more gigabytes
to fully map their users devices. In
this case, we may have to do some
additional resharding, adding a few
suffixes to the client ID. Let's jump
into our highle design. When a device
user first registers to receive
notifications, our client needs to let
one signal know the mapping between the
application ID and the device ID. This
results in an additional entry into the
user mapping table. If our client wants
to register a particular user ID to
belong to a tag group, they just modify
the user tags table. The most important
part of this problem comes when our
client wants to send a notification to a
segment. When they do so, we want to
acknowledge the message quickly. We can
first shove it into Kafka and respond to
our client right after Kafka durably
replicates the message. Since the syntax
for computing the users within a segment
can get pretty complicated, we can't
pre-cache all the data that we could
possibly need on the stream consumer
that'll be handling the message.
Therefore, we'll send a query to our
database tables, meaning that any stream
consumer can compute the users in any
segment. For this reason, our incoming
segments Kafka topic can be roundroin
partitioned. From there, our stream
consumer evaluates the query computing
the set of device IDs for which the
notification must be sent. Ideally,
because we've sorted our tags by the tag
values, queries on the value of an
individual tag should hopefully be fast.
If we have many different tag criteria,
as is the case in this diagram, things
can slow down considerably. Our clients
are expected to understand the
trade-offs of making complicated
segments. After computing the set of
application user IDs that will receive
the notification, we join these with our
user mappings to get all the relevant
device IDs. We partition our user
mappings table by client ID to hopefully
ensure that all of the relevant rows
here are on the same shard. As the
number of users who will receive the
notification gets bigger, the longer
that this query will take. From there,
we'll incue all of the individual
notifications into Kafka. Even if this
number is in the millions or the
billions, we'd be persisting a few
gigabytes of data to many different
Kafka partitions, which can be done in
the span of a few seconds. We can even
bump the batch size of messages that we
send to the Kafka broker at a time,
perhaps to the tens of megabytes to
ensure that the number of actual network
requests stays relatively small. These
notifications can be sent to any
partition of the output Kafka topic and
therefore handled by any consumer. This
is because APNS just exposes a single
endpoint to hit without requiring doing
any special routing on our part.
Speaking of our notification pushing
servers, they subscribe to individual
notification messages from Kafka.
Because they're maintaining persistent
connections with APNS, they're able to
send thousands of push notifications per
second to user devices. In the event
that one of these consumers goes down,
another one may begin reading from its
assigned Kafka partition and send a
duplicate message over to APNS, we can
ensure that we use the same collapse ID
across these messages by just using a
hash of the notification content.
Therefore, the user device won't see
duplicate notifications. In today's deep
dives, we'll talk about how we can
improve our data modeling to speed up
some of our queries. The first thing
that we'll do is talk about secondary
indexes. Recall that one signal
internally stores all tag values as
strings yet supports performing certain
typed operations if those strings could
be interpreted as things like an int or
a date. Assuming that we can do typed
operations, we may need to actually
maintain a secondary index where that
string is stored as a different type.
Here's an example where storing all of
our data as strings can really mess us
up. If we're storing a bunch of numbers
in string form and trying to find all
tags where the value is greater than
five, we may need to do a full table
scan. This is because having leading
zeros on numbers will mess up their sort
order if represented as strings. In a
case like this, we'd want to try to
parse all numbers as ins and maintain a
local secondary index so that we can
actually find all of the tag values that
we care about with a binary search. The
left side of this diagram displays what
we've implemented in our design so far.
That is to say, we first find all tags
that we care about and then we join that
set of user IDs with all of the
individual devices corresponding to
those user IDs. However, we may actually
be able to avoid executing that join
operation in the critical path of
sending notifications to users. Let's
take a look at the right side of the
diagram. This is yet another situation
where we can use stream processing and
change data capture to maintain derived
data. In this case, we'll be using DBZM
to sync both our user mapping and tags
table into Kafka. If we partition both
of them by the one signal client ID and
the user ID, we can perform a
colloccated join. In this case, in our
Kafka streams instances, we'll keep a
mapping of all the devices for a given
user ID and all of the tags for a given
user ID. That way, when either table is
updated, we'll fetch the corresponding
cache data from the other table in
Caucus streams, join them together, and
sync the new results into our
denormalized device tags table. Thank
you to everyone who's made it through
the video. If you have any questions,
because I did brush through a couple of
things a little bit faster than normal,
please feel free to throw them in the
comments section. I'll do my best to get
to them. I guess uh same thing applies
if there's a ton of them. I'm always
going to give priority to the channel
members. Uh but we'll see how that's
going. Anyways, I hope you guys have a
great weekend and I'm looking forward to
seeing you in the next